hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
the importance of cpo carriers within
the healthcare system
presented by dr kenneth thompson a
clinical professor of pathology
and laboratory medicine university of
louisville
school of medicine i'm susie valdez and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by bd
for more information on our sponsor
please visit them at bd.com
now let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab
located on the top right of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits i'd now like to introduce
our presenter dr kenneth thompson from
a complete biography on dr thompson
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr thompson you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
thank you the importance of cpo carriers
within the healthcare system
these are my relevant disclosures
this presentation focuses on the role of
the microbiology laboratory
to prevent the spread of carbopentamize
producing organisms
or cpos with particular emphasis
on the detection of cpo carriers
initially the concern about cpos focused
on
carbapenem resistant enterobacteriaceae
or cre only some of which
are carbopytamine producers
it is now recognized that other
carbopytamines-producing organisms
such as pseudomonas and acetobacter
are increasingly important pathogens and
reservoirs of transmissible carbopylases
hence the focus is now on cpos rather
than just on
cre if we are to detect
cpos in time to prevent their spread
and to successfully treat infected
patients
microbiologists are the only people
capable of doing this
no one else can do it detection is
very important in preventing
transmission
in preventing outbreaks in understanding
the nature
and the extent of cpo problems
and in determining appropriate
therapeutic
and infection prevention and control
approaches
microbiologists are the set of eyes we
rely on
to tell us where the cpos are
cpos are typically multi-drug to totally
resistant
leaving physicians with few to no
therapeutic options
treating with a single drug to which the
organism is susceptible
may be ineffective and trigger the
development
of resistance to all antibiotics
accumulating evidence points to
combination therapy
with active antibiotics being superior
to monotherapy
in terms of preventing mortality and the
development
of total resistance in essence
the clinician may only have one
opportunity to get the patient on
effective
combination therapy as failure to do so
may result in the emergence of total
antibiotic resistance
and doom the patient to die from an
untreatable infection
that is serious cpo infections
take us back to the era of the septic
ward
when there were no effective antibiotics
to treat with
and all physicians could do was observe
their patients
to see if they recovered or died
the cpo problem is now a global pandemic
which cdc has equated to having similar
mortality to ebola cpos continue to
evolve
today there is an increasing number that
are resistant to any or
all of the carbopenems the polymixins
and aminoglycosides
and there is emerging resistance to the
new
beta-lactamase inhibitor combination
ceftazidime
av bacterium how big is the cpa
problem cpos don't just occur in medical
institutions
they are now all over the place and they
and their resistance genes can be
readily transmitted
if we don't have effective interventions
to keep them from doing harm
if you work in a hospital be aware that
hospital waste
water can contain cpos
cpos can also be in the food chain
large scale intensive farming practices
such as crowded factory farming enhance
the opportunity for transmission
and birds eating contaminated foods are
very effective transmitters
as they can fly to different locations
and disperse cpos in their excreta
there are even cpos in remote arctic
regions
you may remember reports during the last
olympic games of cpo contamination of
the beaches and ocean at rio de janeiro
this was due to contaminated hospital
sewage being dumped in the ocean
antibiotic resistant pathogens are now
such a
serious global threat that the united
nations has designated
antimicrobial resistance as one of the
three crisis level health challenges
along with hiv and ebola
there are only three tools we have to
fight against cpos
effective antibiotic therapy antibiotic
stewardship
and infection control
cpo infections are typically treated
with antibiotic combinations
that may include older agents of high
toxicity
such as polymixins and aminoglycosides
of uncertain efficacy such as tiger
cycling
or the new beta-lactamase inhibitor
combinations
even with combination therapy some cpo
infections are untreatable and
resistance continues to escalate
there's a huge push for new antibiotics
to combat
increasing antibiotic resistance
but it's failing utilization of the new
beta-lactamase inhibitor combinations
is hampered by cost concerns and
emerging resistance
the big companies have ceased developing
antibiotics
two of the smaller ones molinta and
archaeagen
that developed some potentially useful
drugs have declared bankruptcy
and others are struggling financially
and may not survive beyond december
in short complacency about new drugs
overcoming the cpo problem would be a
major mistake
this would go against everything we've
learned from the past
about how bacteria continue to evolve
and become
increasingly resistant
so what about antibiotic stewardship
in addition to aims such as cutting
costs and protecting patients from
adverse effects
one of the aims of antibiotic
stewardship is to use
antibiotics judiciously to prevent
further escalation of resistance
by reducing the emergence of de novo
resistance
and reducing the antibiotic selection
pressure
that suppresses susceptible bacteria
thereby enhancing the spread of
antibiotic resistant pathogens
the intentions are excellent but
stewardship only works sometimes the
current status of stewardship
with respect to antibiotic resistance
was recently summarized by schweitzer
and colleagues
who looked into the question of whether
it was being done the right way
they concluded that we really don't know
because we don't have good data from
good studies
that can answer this question quoting
from their paper
the current status of stewardship is
undermined by the poor quality of
research
addressing both what specific
antimicrobial use interventions are
effective
and how antimicrobial use improvement
strategies
can be implemented into practice
so we can only place limited faith in
new antibiotics
and antibiotic stewardship to turn
around the cpo
problem they will work sometimes
but we need something more effective
what about infection prevention and
control
the purpose of infection prevention and
control is to prevent
transmission of pathogens our two main
infection control tools
are hand hygiene and laboratory
detection
disinfection is another tool
in preventing cpo transmission a high
level of compliance with good hand
hygiene
is essential around eighty percent
compliance seems to be associated with
good results
what about laboratory detection
as already mentioned if we don't have
microbiologists to detect cpos
we're working blind and patients will
not be treated appropriately
and cpos will continue to spread
microbiologists are key players
let's take a look at some european
microbiology data
this slide comes from a report showing
the importance of transmission
it was a european study analyzing the
genome sequences
of over resistant klebsiella pneumoniae
from patients in 244 hospitals
in 32 countries approximately a third of
the isolates were cpos
that produced in order of occurrence
kpc oxa48 like ndm
vim and imp carbopenemasers
the major finding was that almost 70
of the cpos belonged to four
clonal lineages and their derivatives
there were transmissions within and
between hospitals
with most transmissions being within
hospitals
that is the hospitals were not
controlling transmission
through not controlling transmission
they were making their own
problem also
cpos had higher transmissibility
than non-carbopythmis producing isolates
another highly predictable finding was
that antibiotic exposure
facilitated the spread of cpos by
reducing the spread of more susceptible
isolates
if you want a short version of the study
heist
highlights i suggest you go to stan
derezinski's commentary in infectious
diseases
in clinical infectious diseases it's
listed here on this slide
so transmission is a big part of the
problem
this makes preventing transmission a
target for intervention
this slide shows how spanish health
professionals
prevented transmission in a nosocomial
outbreak of cre
it's representative of a number of
reports where there has been significant
progress
in reducing the occurrence of cpos and
the infections they cause
in healthcare facilities through
interventions
such as contact precautions patient
isolation or cohorting
hand hygiene and environmental cleaning
in a five-month period they had 18 cases
14 of which were acquired after
admission
environmental testing found seven
percent of the samples to be positive
for the rooms involved hand hygiene was
initiated
and improved compliance from 36 percent
to 85
and there are no positive environmental
samples after hydrogen peroxide
decontamination
in summary having recognized the problem
through microbiological testing
the interventions that worked in this
outbreak were improved compliance with
hand hygiene
and environmental disinfection
microbiological screening the
microbiology laboratory can use
non-molecular and molecular tests to
detect
carriage of cpos
the non-molecular tests are typically
performed after the growth
of bacterial colonies on culture plates
this task can be assisted by the use of
selective differential media
such as chrome agars that can help to
distinguish possible cpos from other
organisms
some representative tests are listed
here
the rapper deck carver np and the
neo-rapid cab kit are manual tests
which detect carbopenium hydrolysis
and the phenix cpo detect is an
automated
mic-based test that detects
and classifies carbopenemasers according
to susceptibility
and inhibition profiles there are also
rapid immunochromatographic assays
such as the ng test carbon 5 that detect
and classify five carbopenemas types
known as the big five these
are carbopenemasers of the kpc ndm
oxford 48 like and vim families
and some but not all imp carbopen amazes
molecular tests vary in what they can
test
with some tests being suitable for both
colonies and direct testing of clinical
samples
ideally carbopenemy screening should be
capable of detecting
all types of carbopenomases
for this reason the non-molecular
screening approach
should focus on rapid phenotypic tests
that detect a wide range of
carbopenemias
sub-optimal tests are those requiring
overnight incubation
or having a limited target range
representative molecular screening
technologies
are shown in this slide our focus today
is on pcr
tests such as the expert carburetor
and the bd max checkpoint cpo
even though these have a limited target
range
comprising the big five this is the
cheapest
and most widely used molecular
carbopytamise detection methodology
microarray testing such as the
checkpoint ct
103xl test offer an extensive
target range but are expensive and more
suited
for for reference laboratory testing
rather than routine screening
for genomic testing there are various
next generation sequencing technologies
but these are not widely available in
clinical laboratories
so let's compare carrier detection by
rapid phenotypic
and pcr tests
this table shows some advantages and
disadvantages
of the rapid tests that can provide a
fast turnaround
time to detect or exclude
cpos from clinical samples
for target range the phenotypic tests
are clear winners
with the automated test having the most
extensive detection range
and the manual tests having good target
ranges but being
unreliable for detecting oxacaba pina
mazes
especially those produced by
synodobacter
the pcr tests can only target the big
five and can have problems with
detecting genes
and coding imp carbopenomases which may
be more common in pseudomonas aeruginosa
than in the enterobacterialis
false positive tests are an issue with
the phenotypic tests
but are rare for pcr tests
amc production and porin mutations
are the most common mechanisms
responsible for false positive
phenotypic tests
phenotypic pcr tests can be used for
direct testing of clinical samples
such as rectal swabs but phenotypic
tests cannot
they require growth of colonies on a
culture plate before the test can be
performed
the phenotypic tests are much cheaper to
do
and the manual phenotypic tests do not
require expensive equipment for the test
to be done
in summary each technology has
advantages and disadvantages
it's really best to have both phenotypic
and molecular tests available then
testing can be tailored to the need
taking into account considerations such
as
urgency cost and whether the
carbopytamines target is known
or unknown expense
is an important factor in test selection
but so too is the consequence of not
detecting a cpo
sometimes it may be necessary to use
both phenotypic
and molecular testing pcr for a rapid
result from a clinical sample
and a phenotypic test if the pcr test is
negative
even if a pcr test on clinical sample is
positive
a culture followed by a phenotypic test
to identify the cpo colonies can be
important
to allow the identification of the
organism performance of an
anti-microbial susceptibility test
and for sending the isolate to a state
laboratory
what happens then if pcr and phenotypic
tests
disagree which is the more accurate
a phantypic test can be positive and a
pcr test negative
when an isolated cap of pen amaze is
outside the target range of the pcr test
for example serration mass systems
isolates sometimes
produce the sme carbopenemas which the
pcr tests cannot detect
you may need to send the isolate to a
reference laboratory
to resolve this type of discordance
what about the reverse if the pcr
test is positive and the phenotypic test
is negative
maybe the pcr result was the correct one
due to the cpo's carbopytami's
expression
being below the threshold of sensitivity
of the phenotypic test
in that case the phenotypic test is
falsely negative
but another possibility is that it was a
false positive pcr
test because it detected dna from
non-viable cells
okay here's an interesting one that i
just can't stop thinking about
two chrome id carber plates inoculated
with the same rectal swab
but one grew lots and lots of cpo
colonies
and the other was negative the story is
this
a rectal swab in transport medium was
received by a hospital laboratory
and tested by bd max checkpoint cpo pcr
test and cultured by streaking on
chromagod
the pcr test was positive for kpc
and the crowmager grew lots of
cpo colonies that can be seen in the
plate on the left
as dark blue colonies on the plate lots
of them
there was also pale there were also
pale pseudomonas aeruginosa colonies on
this plate
the cpa was identified as citrobacter
freundion
rectal swab in transport medium was sent
to another laboratory
where next day it was lawn inoculated
using a hockey stick spreader the
resulting culture on the right
was negative and had heavy overgrowth
of the pseudomonas aeruginosa repeat
attempts
in the second laboratory to recover the
citrobacter frying di from the transport
medium
by both streaking and lawn inoculation
were negative
how do you explain the false negative
second culture
was it the extra day in transport medium
did the pseudomonas produced something
that killed the citrobacter fry in the
eye
this can happen if you ever tested
pseudomonas in modified hodge tests
you may have seen how some pseudomonas
isolates are inhibitory
and cause clearing or no growth in parts
of the e coli lawn
whatever it was in this case the
concerns arising
are that delays in processing rectal
swabs
may result in falsely negative culture
results
and also be aware that a positive pcr
result
when a culture is negative should not
automatically be regarded
as a falsely positive pcr result
now for some issues for the advanced
players what about screening
carbopenem-resistant isolates of
pseudomonas aeruginosa and aciditobacter
a lot of effort and expense can go into
screening them for carbopenomoses
and you may get few or no positives
some points to consider
most carbopenem-resistant pseudomonas do
not
produce a carbopyl other mechanisms
usually cause carbopenem resistance in
this organism
of those that are carbopytamized
positive
the carbopanimase may be one that is not
detected by marketed pcr tests
phenotypic testing is the best means of
determining if the carbopenium
resistance
is or is not caused by a cavapine mase
so if phenotypic carbopenamos testing
should be the first line test
for carbopen and resistance pseudomonas
and pcr
uses the follow-up test that will
identify
some but not all carbopentamizers of
pseudomonas isolates
with carbopenium resistant acinotobacter
approximately ninety percent will be
producing
an oxacaba panama's that is not
included in the big five and cannot be
detected by pcr
the most pragmatic way to deal with
these
is the same way we deal with staph
aureus
approximately ninety percent of staph
aureus isolates
produce a beta-lactamase so we just
assume that a clinical isolate
is beta-lactamase positive without
testing
it makes sense to do the same with a
senator bacteria
oxygen acetobacter are difficult to to
detect
it's easier to assume that the
carbopenium resistant isolates
produce an oxocarbipin amaze
rare isolates will produce other types
of carbopylases
probably more often a metallobeta
lactamase but occasionally a kpc
if you are sending your carbopam
resistant to synatobactor isolates to a
state lab
and they tell you an isolate had a
non-oxicabin
maze then you should start testing for
it
this slide and the next one are largely
based on cdc
and wha recommendations
why do surveillance detection of
asymptomatic colonization
is very important not just to prevent
transmission
but also because often colonization
precedes
infection the cdc and wha
recommend that testing for asymptomatic
colonization
should be do should be guided by local
epidemiology and risk
assessment populations to consider
screening include if a patient has
recently stayed in an institution
with endemic cpos or a hospital in
another country
or been previously colonized or has been
in contact with a colonised
or infected patient another indication
for initiating
surveillance is an unexpected cpo
detection
example the first detection of a cpo in
an institution
or a patient population or the first
detection of a new type of
carbopytamines
or a patient becomes positive 48 hours
or later after admission
also there have been cases at least here
in louisville
where a very gene test on a positive
blood culture
detected a kpc producing e coli
which was carbopenium susceptible and
therefore would
not have been considered a candidate for
carbopytamise testing
in addition to these indications make
sure you follow
any state guidelines
remember early detection is vital to
prevent
transmission be proactive
think about other opportunities for
screening and interventions
in the context of risk assessment and
surveillance testing
based on local epidemiology you may need
to screen admissions from long-term
acute care facilities nursing homes
admissions to critical
care environments such as icus
transplant units and so on
who are at risk and may need periodic
testing during their stay
quite prevalent surveys that involve
testing all patients in a unit
or ward can be effective to rapidly
evaluate the prevalence of cpos in
particular wards or units
this is especially so if previously
unrecognized cpo patients have been
housed
on certain wards or units or to rapidly
evaluate for additional transmission
during an outbreak
a single point prevalence survey might
suffice
if few or no additional cpo colonized
patients
are identified but if ongoing
transmission is occurring
it may be necessary to do more
remember prevalence is a
key performance indicator of ability
to limit the spread of cpos
cdc is big on testing for intestinal
carriage
this is aimed at preventing patient to
patient transmission
and not so much other types of
transmission
links to cdc and wha recommendations
are at the bottom of this slide
now here's one for the thinkers to think
about
while testing for intestinal carriage of
cpos is a major screening focus
what happens when cpo contaminated
excretor gets into hospital waste water
the cpos don't just sit there
they become amplified hospital waste
water contains antibiotics excreted in
urine and stool
creating an environment in which
susceptible bacteria are suppressed
and cpos multiply and transmit their
resistance genes to
other bacteria subsequent waste water
treatment will decrease
but not eliminate pathogens or their
genes
the contaminated wastewater and sludge
which is the particulate matter in
sewerage
are then released daily into rivers and
farmland
sludge farms these are farms with a lake
for dumping sludge
into and the lake may receive something
like
50 truckloads of sludge daily
in which the process of cpo
amplification continues
so what is this to do with screening
there are now many papers about cpos in
hospital wastewater
if you screen a hospital's wastewater
a positive screen may indicate current
or past cpo carriage by patients
and also indicate the risk to patients
through being splashed by contaminated
waste water
from sink drains and high pressure
flushing of hoppers
and toilets on the other hand
a negative screen of wastewater may
indicate there is not
a cpo problem in your hospital
it's something to think about if you're
interested
this slide has some links to studies in
this area
in conclusion there should be
no complacency about the future of the
cpo problem
without effective counter measures the
prevalence of cpo carriage of cpos
and of cpo infections with bad outcomes
can be expected to increase
of the three potentially effective
countermeasures
new anti-cpo antibiotics antibiotic
stewardship
and infection prevention and control
infection prevention and control is
currently the most effective
the most crucial components of infection
prevention and control
are effective hand hygiene and rapid cpo
detection
in this context microbiologists must
continue to be first-line responders
in an evolving and complex clinical
challenge
and to be prepared to perform whatever
testing
is necessary preventing the spread of
cpos
requires effective teamwork from all
three key players
infection prevention and control
antibiotic stewardship
and microbiology and acting
quickly is vital this means that using
the most effective overall notifications
which is often the telephone
to avoid delays given the series of cpos
and the bleakness of the future if they
become endemic
and the critical need for
microbiological surveillance
failure by laboratories to provide the
speed
and quality of testing that is needed
would be
unacceptable thank you i'll now open
open this up for questions
thank you dr thompson for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question
box located on the far left of your
screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions coming in from our audience
members
now dr thompson
which phenotypic test do you recommend
for detecting carbapenemesis in
pseudomonas aeruginosa
isolates uh
we've looked at both the rapper dec
carbure np and the rosco
test both of them work very well
don't use the modified hodge or sim test
both of these are too slow and the
modified hodge test is a terrible test
its known accuracy problems are even
worse with pseudomonas
than with enterobacteriaceae
the bd phoenix cpo detect test is
excellent for oxalis and
enterobacteriaceae and acidobacter
but it can miss bims and pseudomonas
aeruginosa
thank you for that and how do you get
started to develop a screening
protocol
if you've never done screening you could
start with a point prevalence study to
see
what you have in your patient population
if it's the issue of
developing a protocol and you don't have
you don't have to invent it from scratch
you can go to the cdc and who links in
this presentation for good information
about how to develop a protocol
thank you and thank you for our audience
member questions coming in
these are wonderful what is your
inspection control
does it not see benefit in screening for
cpo carriers
could you say that again please what if
your infection control does not see
benefit
in screening for cpo carriers
not saying benefit is a different issue
from not having the resources or the
institutional support for screening
if infection control does not see
benefit
there is a need for education cpas are
different from other gram-negative
pathogens
and the consequences of exit acquisition
can be very bad this needs to be
understood
educate about things like unacceptably
high mortality associated with cpo
infections
and the vital role of infection
prevention and control
cannot be over emphasized
cpos have become an international
priority with the who
proposing international regulations that
require countries to report events
of new or emerging antibiotic resistance
especially
cpos if you want to talk costs
cpas generate enormous costs associated
with not
detecting and not controlling spread
then there are costs to patients
what about the homeowner admitted to
hospital complaining of abdominal pain
and a lot of difficulty urinating
he gets a cpo infection and a few months
later the hospital owns his house and
he's leaving with his toe tagged
lots of reasons to screen for cpos
thank you for that our next question
coming in from an audience member
is how is waste water tested dr thompson
there's no standardized methodology for
testing wastewater
for getting samples some places
uh swab the surface of pipes
uh if you want to get the water you can
get it from a youtube under a sink
or open a manhole cover and drop a jar
in attached to a string
and collects a large volume of water
50 to 200 mils say maybe centrifuges
and then you can test by
depositing the culture on a culture
plate the deposit on a culture plate and
culturing it
or using pcr or even next generation
sequencing methods
this is a new area i think it's probably
a good idea to at least once
assess the status of a hospital's
wastewater plumbing
and if necessary to take appropriate
interventions
some studies suggest that even weekly
testing
is a good idea
thank you dr thompson and do you have
any research
on patient outcome information on
hospitals that have screening versus not
screening
um i don't have any specific data
that i can think of off the top of my
head but i would think that
if there are cpas around hospitals
that do have a screening program can get
on top of the
transmission quickly whereas those that
don't have a screening program
the they're going to have a
an antibiotic resistance emergency on
their hands
and the bigger it gets the longer it's
delayed
and dr thompson what does a testing
protocol look like
a testing protocol a protocol is a
list of instructions on how to do
something
so uh you can
it's it's a methodology in writing a
protocol
or a flow chart and
again i refer you to the cdc
and the world health organization links
that i put on one of the slides
thank you and we have another question
from an audience member about
that cpo screening why do you feel cpo
screening has not been adopted
as widely as mrsa screens
why hasn't it been adopted as widely as
mrsa
screening um
part of that i i think we've dropped the
ball to a certain extent
the uh first transmissible
carbopenemasers were reported around
about
1990. it was about 20 years later that a
test was recommended by clsi
and cdc and that was the modified hodge
test so there was a big
window there where we weren't even
thinking of screening
and then a few years later the
break points for carbopenem testing were
lowered
and it was felt that uh just getting an
mic is
sufficient to detect carbopentamizers
and uh often it is but uh there was a
study came out
a bit over a year ago where about uh ten
percent of isolates that produced a
carbopylase and a surveillance study
were carbopenium susceptible uh so i
i think they're reasons why we don't
haven't done as much cpo screening as
mrsa screening
a slow start and then the changing of
the break points thank you and again
thank you to our audience members for
these questions coming in we have time
for a couple more questions
dr thompson what should you do if a
pseudomonas uh is positive
by phenotypic testing but negative by
pcr
um the thing to do if you have a
cavipanimas producing pseudomonas by
phenotypic testing but your
pcr test is negative would be send it to
a state health lab
they should be able to confirm a wider
range of carbopen amazes than the
big five that are in our commercial pcr
tech kits
thank you and our final question for you
today is
how good is the point prevalence survey
approach
one of the advantages of the point
prevalence survey approach
is that you get information about the
extent of the problem
the difficulty with it is that it takes
time
to organize a survey and for culture
results to become available and in that
time
patients who were present on a ward at
the same time
as the index patient may have been
discharged or moved to another ward
so that's the disadvantage
thank you very much dr thompson and i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions and
remind you that questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr thompson via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
before i go i want to thank you again dr
thompson for your time today and for
your important research
and i'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor bd
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day bye
you